As we seek the Lord together today, I want to read a prayer
from Reverend Timothy Merritt, who was a pastor in the
Northeast in the 1700s and 1800s.
Let's pray together.
"O Almighty and most merciful God,
permit a penitent sinner to come into Thy presence and make
supplication unto Thee.
Thou, O Lord, art holy and highly exalted, but
I am unworthy and exceedingly vile.
I'm a fallen creature, and my soul is defiled within me.
Thou requirest truth in the inward parts, but I
am filled with iniquity. Behold, I was conceived in
sin, and like the wild donkey's colt, I have been prone to go
astray from the beginning of my days.
My heart departed from Thee, and my desires and
affections became fixed on many objects.
My will grew perverse and stubborn.
My understanding was darkened.
From the head even unto the foot, there is no health in me,
but I am full of wounds and bruises.
My whole head is sick, my whole heart is faint,
and I have this further addition to my native
depravity,
that when You put into my hands the means of purifying myself from all
filthiness of flesh and spirit,
I did not use them for this purpose.
Thou hast opened a fountain for my sin and uncleanness, but I have not washed
away my sin. But I have been indifferent.
I have been lukewarm when I ought to be filled with holy resolution
and zeal.
My conduct has been marked with the greatest ingratitude
in delaying my perfect cleansing, and the evil
propensities of my nature have struck deeper root and entrenched themselves in
my heart.
That I have not wholly drifted away from You
is only because of Your tender mercy
and not to any virtue of my own."
Let's continue praying and seeking the Lord and humbling
ourselves before Him,
that He might show us our heart and any areas of impurity there.